by now I think we're all familiar with
onetime passcodes they're the pesky but
required six-digit codes that enable to
factor authentication and keep all of
our accounts secure from hackers and
Bots most of us have likely never given
otps much thought it's just a normal
part of the modern tech world but it's
actually a massive industry supporting
several massive players you of course
have your classic big tech companies
including Google's identity platform and
and Amazon's Cognito you've probably
also heard of dual mobile and OCTA but
have you ever heard of a company called
twio twio is arguably the king of
automated text messages and emails with
a peak market cap of over $70
billion this means that at their Peak
they were one of the top 250 largest
companies in the world but more recently
things haven't been looking so bright
for this OTP Giant in fact twilio stock
has fallen 85% bringing their market cap
all the way down to just over12 billion
it's easy to write off this decline as
just a byproduct of the volatile market
and recession fears but there seems to
be more to twilio story not only did
they fall much further than big Tech but
they have yet to see any sort of
recovery and when you take a look at
their financial reports it all starts to
make sense you see twilio has never been
a profitable company having relied on V
funding and stock dilution to keep the
business running this strategy works
when revenue is growing exponentially
but not so much when Revenue starts to
stall out and that's exactly what's
happening to twilio who is very much
stalling out at the $4 billion Mark to
make things worse it doesn't seem like
their expenses are getting any better
meaning that twilio is currently burning
well over a billion dollars every single
year with only $3.5 billion left in the
bank this is not exactly an ideal
situation for the company and it's no
wonder why investors are staying away so
join me as we take a look at the rise
and fall of the king of otps and whether
twilio will ever return to their former
glory taking a look back twio didn't
start off as an OTP company because well
otps weren't even a thing when twio was
founded back in 2007 the main guy behind
twilio was a software developer and
serial entrepreneur named Jeff Lawson
Jeff was a former AWS product manager
who was obsessed with perfecting user
experiences in fact Jeff strongly
believes that this is the main job of
software Engineers to iteratively
understand customers and build better
and better Solutions using software but
despite founding three companies before
tlio Jeff couldn't help but feel that he
was constantly falling short in this
area and to him the reason was off
obvious a lack of communication with
traditional businesses whether it's a
retail store or a restaurant you're
constantly able to interact with your
customers and get a better feel for what
they like what they don't like and what
could be improved but with software
while you're able to reach more
customers than any traditional business
you're also far more disconnected from
your customers aside from a random
review that might pop up from time to
time there's really no way to directly
communicate with customers so Jeff
started looking into ways that he could
set up communication infrastructure
himself which is when he ran into a
massive reality check it turns out that
building out a communications platform
is far harder than building out a
software platform according to Jeff
himself H was used to software
development timelines in the weeks
building out this communication
infrastructure however would take 2 to 3
years and $2 to3
million put off by the cost and timeline
Jeff would start looking into big Tech
Solutions which is when he realized that
there was none and that's when it hit
him if he needed to communicate with
customers it's likely that other
developers did as well and if there was
no established Solutions on the market
then maybe he could be that solution and
with that we saw the birth of twio a
company that was going to make
Communications between software
companies and users easier than ever the
journey to build this company however
was by no means easy the problem was
that Jeff needed VC money and no VC
really understood what he was trying to
do in fact Jeff started off with what he
deemed to be a safe pitch a pitch to a
person that he knew pretty well but this
person would end up laughing Jeff out of
the room asserting that Jeff would need
an insane amount of salespeople to get
this off the ground this disappointing
outcome made it clear to Jeff that he
needed proof before he approached the
VCS so instead of pitching he would get
to work he would build a simple voice
API that was hosted on the cloud that
could make and receive phone calls and
they would launch it on November 20th
2008 keep in mind this was a couple of
months before even Google Voice came out
so twilio was very much early to the
game and as such they were able to land
some pretty big clients pretty quickly
this included the likes of Cheetos Earth
911 Tumblr and Sony Music it turned out
that tulo voice was also super helpful
for politicians who wanted to automate
the process of calling voters with these
customers in his back pocket Jeff would
return to the VC table and let's just
say he would be taken a lot more
seriously in early 2009 trilia would
complete a seed funding round raising
$600,000 if you're familiar with Chris
Saka from Shark Tank he was one of
trillo's seed investors they would
followed this up with a series a round
of funding just a couple of months later
raising $3.7 million now that twio had
money Jeff would double down on his
sales effort according to Jeff the key
to Growing twilio was treating
developers like customers you see a lot
of Enterprise companies get into the
habit of treating developers as second
tier customers and it's no wonder why
when you're serving developers
considerations like public reputation
and brand image aren't nearly as
important not to to mention there's only
a handful of developer solutions for any
given market so developers aren't that
likely to switch to another service
provider in the first place so companies
often tend to treat developers as just a
strategy to reach more end users and
make their experience even better as a
software developer Jeff was all too
aware of this reality and he wanted twio
to be different he wanted twio to put
developers first and treat developers as
customers and this has really been their
strategy
they would sponsor hackathons run
hackathons and hand out a bunch of
shirts to developers in fact at one
point Jeff would make the prediction
that twilio would hand out more shirts
to developers than Blackberry would ship
phones looking back this wasn't too hard
given that Blackberry would fall off a
cliff but I think you get the idea
twilio was reaching a lot of developers
as their reach grew twio also focused on
expanding their product line which led
to the creation of their text messaging
API in February of 2010 initially this
wasn't meant for otps rather it was
meant for updating customers for example
messages like your shipment is on the
way or your package is out for delivery
it wasn't until mid 2011 that too
launched their shortcode API platform
and this is when all of Jeff's original
worries came back to life with their
voice API and original SMS API
infrastructure wasn't too big of a
concern because the volume wasn't too
large but with otps companies would be
sending out Millions if not tens of
millions of messages on a daily basis so
not only did twio need strong
infrastructure but they also needed Rock
Solid deals with carriers to process and
send so many text messages twio also had
to worry about preventing spam and abuse
of the platform to be honest toio never
really figured out the solution to this
issue but luckily for twilio investors
had back in 2007 investors didn't quite
understand the value of twilio but by
the early 2010s they knew exactly what
they were in for and they were willing
to back twilio to the moon this included
$12 million in late 2010 17 million in
late 2011 130 million in 2015 and 150
million IPO in
2016 that's really how twio addressed
the infrastructure problem they just
raised and spent a bunch of money but
while that worked in the early days as
Tulio became a mature company investors
started looking for profitability and
Roi which brings us into twilio's
current
[Music]
crisis the reality is that twio is
having an extremely rough time achieving
profitability they've already tried
doing layoffs multiple times actually
last September they laid off 11% of
their staff and earlier this year they
laid off another 177% of their staff So
within the past year alone they've cut
their Workforce by almost a third and
they're still burning over a billion
dollars per year and the reality is that
this situation is more a result of the
industry as opposed to twilio themselves
you see the communications API industry
has become extremely Cutthroat
especially with Google and Amazon
stepping into the arena these
juggernauts view the industry in a
completely different light to them the
communications API industry is just a
small portion of one sector of one
division of their business they frankly
don't care about the sector more than
just controlling it and telling their
Enterprise customers that they offer
these Solutions as well AKA Google nor
Amazon really care about their SMS
business being profitable for them it's
all about the bigger picture it's about
locking in Walmart or Ford as their next
massive Cloud customer if that means
that Walmart and Ford get subsidized
otps so be it it's more than worth it
the same however cannot be said about
twilio whose main business itself is
Communications meaning that this itself
has to be profitable and according to
twio themselves they don't expect Gap
profitability till
2027 with that being said the good news
is that twio has a really strong pool of
customers including Uber Airbnb
instacart Reddit and lift just to name a
few and it's unlikely that these
companies will move away from twilio
anytime soon because twilio has won over
the developers at these companies with
their developer first mindset and as
long as twio has a strong roster of
customers it's unlikely that investors
will stop supporting twio worst case
scenario they have a couple of rough
years until they achieve profitability
after which they'll be good to go also
Google and Amazon are by no means trying
to take down twio in fact they actually
support twio just recently twio
partnered with Google to create better
AI powered virtual customer support and
Amazon has even gone as far far as
investing in fio buying up a 1% stake in
the company but at the same time this
could also be perceived as bad news you
have a strong company with strong
customers that's facing a cash flow
problem that makes them the perfect
acquisition Target Google and Amazon
could easily put up the $12 billion to
buy the company and they would have a
far easier time handling the expenses
with their in-house infrastructure they
may even be able to achieve
profitability with twio but even even if
they don't it doesn't really matter
because they would have a new list of
customers that they could sell Google
cloud or AWS to for the sake of twilio
and in hopes are preventing big Tech
from controlling yet another industry
hopefully twilio is able to make it
through on their own but only time will
tell another Fallen giant that's
surprisingly beating the odds is Nokia
check out this video to learn more but
until then I'm Harry and I'll see you
guys on the next
one